[Music]
miniature horse or the cutest most
beautiful British baby never step down I
love doing this movie because you made
me laugh so many times yeah it's your
first real comedy though right
how fun was that the first one yeah I
guess and so is a teenager maybe no it's
really fun everybody I really wanted to
do one for ages I may have played a kind
of a lot of serious Psychopaths so I
sort of sort of play a funny psychopath
in the theme of this movie damsel your
favorite boss-lady damsel that you've
ever had the pleasure of working with
obviously Kristin Scott Thomas Kristen
Stewart cuz I saw you guys just hung out
the other day validity of my feelings
and you can go to hell
talk to me about it being a feminine
twist on a Western we don't see that a
lot with western movies was that kind of
part of the draw for you yeah I mean
it's kind of seemed kind of subversive I
mean I think most westerns the the
archetype Rock could have lead cowboy as
someone who stood and they can handle
anything and it's just damn against the
world and they come to save save the
damsel but I mean it's my pretty much
every single male character in this
movie is completely inept and I mean and
everyone think they think they're trying
to save the thing that doesn't save the
damsel bachelor and capable of anything
they're incapable of saving themselves
we loved watching Robert Pattinson on
the big screen for years this November
marks the tenth anniversary of the first
Twilight film what if I'm not the hero
wanna find the bad guy
what would you today ten years later
here you are promoting this amazing
movie
save yourself walking onto that set for
the first time I mean just have fun I
mean it's kind of the whole Wiseman
really great I mean has since I am spin
incredibly lucky in my career in my life
and yeah I'm already appreciative of
everything